this is I think a very fun role for you  in gringo because you get to do so many  different things I love your characters  very likeable very sweet very gullible  as he said there's a there's an  improbable scene where you get to show  off your rapping skills oh yeah I didn't  think was really going to be it didn't  really I didn't think of a fit your  character but then you realize it does  well but the thing about that as well is  that Nash Edgerton our director only  told me that we were going to do that  scene two days before we actually shot  it and it was at Will Smith getting  jiggy with it so that's pretty hardcore  rap oh yeah we're going to be for that  one so ya know I had to channel Big  Willie in the in the in the movie and  but I I had to learn the song in these  two two days my poor kids I just had the  thing on a loop for I have to learn the  song yes your father is working right  now exact  you